If many of you work in a corporation,
you may have noticed that most of you
are using similar laptops or similar
desktop computers. If everyone has
similar equipment, it becomes much
easier to update, much easier to manage,
and ultimately much easier to secure.
One of the things we have to worry about
is someone bringing in a non-compliant
system. This would be a system that is
not part of the standard operating
environment or the S SOE. The S SOE
commonly consists of computers that have
been thoroughly checked, a specific set
of software has been installed, and
everything on that system is up to date
with the latest security requirements
for the organization. And keeping these
systems in compliance is an ongoing
process. Every time there's a patch or
an update, we have to check that patch
and make sure that it doesn't affect the
security of the system in any way. So if
there is an operating system update, an
application patch, or anything else that
changes on that system, we have to test
it before deploying it into the field.
Someone connecting a non-compliant
system to the network makes an easy
place for an attacker to gain access to
all of your data. So we commonly put
hardware and software in place to look
for any of these non-compliance systems.
For example, many organizations have an
active directory infrastructure and that
allows them to set group policies to
enable or disable aspects of the
operating system. Many organizations
will also implement next generation
firewalls so that they can see every bit
of data that's traversing their network
and they know every application that's
in use. They can also set policies to
allow or disallow access to individual
applications. And one of the things that
you probably don't see are the ongoing
scans occurring behind the scenes by
your IT department to see if they can
locate any devices on the network that
shouldn't be there.
An unpatched system contains known
vulnerabilities that an attacker could
use to gain access to those systems. For
that reason, we are very diligent about
making sure that we are patching and
updating all of the systems on our
network. You've probably seen this on
Microsoft Patch Tuesday. This is the
second Tuesday of every month where
Microsoft releases the latest batch of
updates for their operating systems.
Very commonly up until patch Tuesday, no
one knew that those vulnerabilities
existed. But the moment that Microsoft
introduces those patches, the entire
world is now informed of any security
vulnerabilities. From that point
forward, the race is on. Your
organization needs to test all of these
patches and then deploy them to every
device in the network. At the same time,
the attackers are writing exploits to be
able to take advantage of these brand
new vulnerabilities. The winner of this
race is going to be the one that is able
to deploy these patches first or the one
that is going to create exploits first.
If you're going to win this race, you
need to make sure that you have a
process in place for testing and
deploying these systems as quickly as
possible. That's easier said than done
because many organizations will have
hundreds or even thousands of devices
that need to be patched. This is why a
lot of organizations have built an
entire series of processes and
procedures to push out these patches to
every device as quickly as possible.
They also know that missing any of these
devices could be a critical flaw. If a
device doesn't get these patches, then
it will be susceptible to these new
exploits. So we have to make sure that
we are not only covering all of the
devices on our network, we're also
making sure that we haven't missed any
of these devices during the update
process. We are constantly working to
make this patching process more
efficient. So as we are testing,
prioritizing, and deploying these
patches, we're finding ways to improve
the efficiency and the speed at getting
all of these updates out to all of our
systems.
Security in an organization is often
seen as a roadblock or something that is
preventing the organization from
performing the task that they need. In
reality, of course, the security is put
in place to make the data in the systems
as safe as possible. But often we find
that certain applications or certain
systems will simply not work properly
with the existing security in place. We
might also find times when our
troubleshooting process makes a system
less secure. For example, you may need
to disable anti virus during
troubleshooting to make sure that it's
not anti virus that's causing our
problem. Or maybe we need to disable our
personal firewall and see if that's
causing the communications problem that
we are experiencing. What we have to
remember is at the end of our
troubleshooting task to make sure that
we have reenabled anti virus, reenabled
our firewall, or that we have an
automated process in place to
automatically reenable those security
tools. Some individuals in an
organization might feel that if anti
virus is causing the problem then we
should disable anti virus or if the
personal firewall is causing this
problem then we should disable the
personal firewall. Fortunately, many
organizations have evolved past the
point of simply turning off security to
circumvent those problems and instead
addressing each individual issue as a
way to troubleshoot and resolve security
issues so that all of these can work
together.
It's said that all good things must come
to an end eventually, and that's
certainly true in the world of operating
systems. We've certainly seen migrations
in operating systems through the years,
and it's not uncommon to upgrade or
replace operating systems as they get
older. Most operating systems have a
publicly stated timeline on when that
operating system is active. And
eventually, there will be an endoflife
date associated with that operating
system. We refer to this as the EOL
date. This is when the manufacturer
stops selling that operating system, but
they may still continue to support the
operating system going forward for a
certain amount of time. So although
there might not be any new features over
the next 2 years with this operating
system, we will still continue to get
security patches and minor updates that
fix problems with the operating system.
A significant date, especially one that
is a concern for security professionals,
is the end of service life or EOSL. This
is when the manufacturer is not selling
the operating system and they are no
longer supporting the operating system.
This means if a security vulnerability
is found in that software, it's unlikely
that this company will be producing any
patches or updates. In some
circumstances with very large companies,
you might have the option to have a
premium cost support option that
provides extended coverage for an
additional time frame. However, this is
not the norm for most organizations. And
if you do have equipment that is at its
end of service life, you might want to
consider swapping that out for something
that's more supportable.
Many of us own our own mobile phone, but
we also use that same phone when we're
at work. We refer to this as bring your
own device or bring your own technology.
The employee brings their phone, but
also includes company data and company
applications on that same phone. This
brings up some interesting security
concerns because we want to be sure that
that phone provides the proper security,
especially if the company's data happens
to exist on that device. Many
organizations have implemented mobile
device managers or MDMs to solve some of
the problems that we have with combining
these two devices into one single
device. For example, it's both a home
device and a work device at the same
time, which means we have personal data
and corporate data on that same device.
How are we planning to protect the data?
Many mobile device managers will
partition away part of the device for
home data and part of the device for
corporate data. If you leave the
organization, that MDM simply deletes
the corporate data, leaving your private
information intact. The same concern
occurs if someone wants to upgrade their
phone or they want to sell the phone to
someone else. Once they get a new phone,
they need to go through the process of
adding all the corporate data. But we
also have to think about how we remove
the corporate data from the old device
as well. This is another place where a
mobile device manager can be valuable
because from that central MDM console,
you can select any device and choose to
delete all of the data on that device.
That MDM is also good for adding
security policies onto these devices. So
they will monitor for any changes and
look for any type of malicious software.
This prevents an attacker from infecting
our mobile device which ultimately may
allow the attacker access to our
corporate data.